Caitlyn Jenner gets a major honor I'm
reminding you you promised me another
interview oh I know baby you're gonna
get it you got anyway and we are you are
going to get that don't you worry
and gives props to dad to be Rob
Kardashian things are going well Caitlyn
Jenner and Diane Sawyer accepted the
award for outstanding at TV journalism
at Saturdays at GLAAD Media Awards in
New York the honor was for Diane's
2015 is special on Caitlyn's transition
I think was so moving how many people
came to learn and stayed to learn and
we're on social media talking about it
together and it was almost as if we were
all learning together almost a classroom
a classroom out together but also an
experience of the heart you know what I
remember after it was over with and you
know we were six months after it and I
thought what have we accomplished with
that and then Vanity Fair and then the
show and all that sort of stuff what we
did is we opened up the conversation and
while ET was with Caitlyn backstage we
had to get her take on her stepson
Rob Kardashian you know what everybody
goes through tough times in their life
and deals with a lot of different thing
I always look at it
everybody has their stuff you know and
it's how you deal with your stuff and
how you come out the other end so yeah
things are going well